Could there be a real contest at the Democratic
convention for the nomination?
Very unlikely.
The way the Democratic rules work, Hillary
Clinton is almost certain to get enough delegates
to win the nomination.
But there could be fireworks, or at least
intrigue, at that Democratic convention in
Philadelphia because Sanders is going to come
in with 40% or more of the delegates and a
strong and ardent base that doesn’t start
out with enthusiasm for the Democratic nominee.
So Bernie Sanders might ask to change the
platform
to promote a single payer health care system
to promote a return to Glass-Steagall
and a strong pledge to breakup the big banks.
He could make a strong pitch to take on the
trade issue in a tougher way than the platform
would normally do.
Or Sanders could ask for a choice of running
mate that might include an Elizabeth Warren
or a Sherrod Brown or somebody else who has
the same kind of ardent populist views that Sanders
does.